people are afraid of AI right and it's
not that it's going to take away our
jobs it's that I don't know what's going
to happen to me the fear isn't losing
the job the fear is what's next and so
if we think back you
know uh 30 years ago something like 80%
of the jobs that exist today didn't
exist prior to the internet you know it
Consulting was not a robust business we
now it's standard The Narrative isn't
your job is going to go away the
narrative is your job is going to change
and I'll give one example I'll give me
right so in my world the writer is king
and the editor is disposal what AI Can
Do Is Write a bad first draft unless
it's an original idea so like let's take
a press release we pay a press we pay a
PR person a lot of money because they
know how to write a press release right
that's the hard part and then the rest
of us get our grubby hand on it right
that'll change that'll change cuz now
chat gbt been write a bad first draft of
a press release but the editor is going
to be the
hero and so we're going to replace
writers with
editors um and so to use that example
that the job's not going away the
balance would sh I'll give you another
example in the United States the IRS a
bunch of years ago digitized taxes it
used to be you send in the form and
teams and teams and teams that
accountants read through our tax forms
and they replac it all with computers
and they offered this Mass of savings
you know how much the government
actually saved when we digitized
taxes zero because yes they got rid of
all the accountants but then they had to
boost up the it departments because now
all the computers were playing reading
the taxes the net savings was Zero the
jobs changed didn't go away they just
change the net savings will be
zero you're going to have to pay editors
more you're going to have to pay what
you used to pay writers instead of
talking about your job is going away
which is a nedit we start talking about
the new jobs that are going to be
available I think that gets people
excited because again they're not afraid
of losing their jobs they're afraid of
that there's no job for them and so we
start talking about all the new jobs
that are going to exist like prompt
editor you know all of these things that
are going to happen it's the uncertainty
that freaks them out so all have to do
is paint a picture of a little more
certainty than we have now